não sofre golos há mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer uma mini
espingarda usando uma caneta
vocês podem ver que podem tirar a bola e
idéias softball de papel uma coisa por
físico juntar 50 anos de ficar eu fizer
uma cola teve a polícia um pouco maior
do que o normal mas se você estiver em
um dos outros não tem problema nenhum
podem usar isso também
a única diferença que é para uma
bandeira da vossa arma vai ficar mais
pequena para que os políticos é que na
posição certa e um conselho que vocês
vêem uma fita e punham a volta de forma
que os políticos fiquem todos encostados
uns aos outros por fazer o cano de uma
caneta destas aqui dizer na verdade não
precisa ser igual o importante é ter o
mesmo sistema e por isso tirei esta
parte cônica deixa ela vem limpa corta e
alma em outro pacto por juntar as duas
partes eu vou usar uma cola com dois
componentes
mas vocês não se usar a mesma super cola
podem usar outra coisa qualquer
aí é muito importante que você estava
aqui este buraco no lado direito
por isso usei super cola e produzindo
bem pequenino de um palito de picolé foi
muita atenção vocês têm que cortar é
parte do atraso quinta na caneta e isso
vai depender um pouco do museu da crença
que vocês utilizaram o importante é que
a caneta volta a funcionar com
funcionava antes ou seja que eu fiz até
agora foi diminuir o tamanho da caneta e
nesse processo eu conseguir fazer um
pedacinho do cano que eu vou sentar pois
na parte da frente e é lá que eu vou
colocar as balas como vocês vão viajar
do frida
aqui nesta parte preta e depois em caixa
o cano que a frente e ali que vão
colocar as balas falar em balas não
tinha como fazer uma utilizando o papel
que é bastante simples vocês têm que
cortar uma faixa papel quando uma parte
é maior e outra mais pequenina depois
começou a enrolar da parte maior para a
parte mais pequena e no final vocês têm
primeiro pesando fita já está feito ou
seja o mais importante ela já está feito
e agora só falta fazer a coronha base
mas se usar os políticos que o plano no
início do vídeo por ter anotado por
sozinho e não outra metade
e como vocês podem ver de uma forma
assim bastante rudimentar
agora se vocês quiserem idéia é seguir
ao google e procurar por imagem darmos
que vocês gostem cuja suíte restante
precisará ter chegarem ao design que
vocês fizeram em cima desses políticos
por incitar uma parte à outra da escola
que depois encontrei esse problema
sozinho aqui as bolas das só não chegava
a opção preto
então eu tirei um prazo uma vez que a
bola ficava mais dois e kanu e assim os
tipos de um com mais força no final
estava demonstrado aqui o meu mini o
robozinho que vou fazer um vídeo mais
para frente não sei quando mas eu tenha
dado estar bastante fazer coisas com ele
uma vez que dá para programar sem saber
nada de programação utilizando o
programa em bloco e você só tem que ter
uma noção do lógica e é bastante simples
mesmo e acho que vocês vão gostar
bastante do vídeo sobre este robô
estiverem sugestões de coisas que eu
posso fazer com ela é só deixar nos
comentários
e vou tentar aproveitar algumas
sugestões para fazer no vídeo do roubo e
vejam como é que funciona basicamente é
um servo numa tecla é eu cantar contra o
campeão eo disparo
é isso que espero nenhum estado nem isso
estão inscritos e os comentários que
isso muito obrigado até a próxima
champions e companhia rosas e truncado
constipado